perquisitions dans les domiciles de
roland dumas président du conseil
constitutionnel dans le cadre d'une
affaire de pots de vin à l'occasion d'un
important marché et militaires émotion
aux obsèques des collégiens de montigny
le bretonneux une foule de plusieurs
milliers de personnes à assister
cérémonie le débat sur les 35 heures est
ouvert à l'assemblée nationale pour
l'instant les positions restent très
éloignées entre majorité et opposition
plusieurs défilés ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui hillary clinton la première
dame des etats-unis vient au secours du
président elle dénonce un complot
politique
la coupe du monde de football un très
beau spectacle en perspective mais aussi
l'énorme entreprise qui va générer des
profits considérables bref une affaire
en or pour les sponsors c'est notre
enquête
ce soir là monsieur bonsoir la justice
s'est intéressée aujourd'hui à l'un des
tout premiers personnages de l'état
gardien des institutions en tant que
président du conseil constitutionnel
roland dumas ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères de françois
mitterrand est actuellement en compagnie
de deux juges d'instruction eva joly
laurence vichnievsky dans le cadre d'une
affaire de commissions touchées à
l'occasion d'un important marché
d'armement signés fin 91 au profit de
taiwan 45 millions c'est la somme en
question y at il un lien entre cette
commission et roland dumas
c'est ce que les juges veulent savoir et
c'est pour cette raison qu'ils ont
perquisitionné aujourd'hui le bureau et
les deux domiciles de l'ancien ministre
à paris et dans un petit village de
giron rivier caroff christopher l'image
symbole d'une perquisition spectaculaire
roland dumas encadré de laurence
vichnievsky eva joly les deux juges
d'instruction qui enquêtent depuis
plusieurs mois sur une affaire
d'escroquerie où son nom est cité avec
insistance
tôt ce matin accompagné d'hommes de la
brigade financière elles ont d'abord
perquisitionné les bureaux privés de
roland dumas
sous les yeux du président du conseil
constitutionnel
les enquêteurs emportent les premiers
documents de cette perquisition qui ne
prendra fin qu'à la nuit tombée vers 13
heures le trio se rend rue de bièvre
domicile de roland dumas dans les
archives de l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères eva joly et laurence
vichnievsky s'intéresserait en
particulier aux relevés de compte en
banque
la police se chargent d'éloigner les
curieux elle s'occupe aussi d'amener des
cartons supplémentaire pour remporter de
nouveaux documents parallèlement
d'autres policiers perquisitionnent la
résidence secondaire de roland dumas en
gironde
à paris les deux juges d'instruction
vont rester près de 6 dans l'appartement
de l'ancien min
à la sortie elle prendre bien soin
d'éviter toute apparition
pas question de prêter le flanc aux
éventuelles accusations de pratiques et
une justice médiatique
ce soir donc les perquisitions les
différentes perquisitions sont terminés
au départ de la faire il faut y venir la
vente donc de six frégates au régime de
taiwan c'était à la fin de l'année 91
une amie de roland dumas qui aurait
touché une commission confortable une
tentative d'escroquerie
la société thomson le pétrolier elf qui
auraient également pris part au marché
bref un écheveau très difficile à
démêler
michèle fines septembre 1990 le ministre
des affaires étrangères de roland dumas
est l'invité de l'heure de vérité au
milieu du public
une femme christine deviers-joncour à
l'époque chargé de mission au quai
d'orsay
cet ami très proche de roland dumas est
aujourd'hui à l'origine de ses ennuis
depuis trois mois
christine deviers-joncour est en prison
mêlé à une sombre affaire d'escroquerie
sur fond de contrats d'armements 1991
thompson au vent six frégates militaires
au gouvernement de taïwan un marché
énorme de 15 milliards de francs
la chine ne voulait pas de ce contrat le
quai d'orsay non plus pourtant ils ont
signé cet homme
alfred sirven éminence grise d'elf
aquitaine la firme c'est grâce à lui que
la vente aurait été conclue sirven
réclame son dû dix pour cent de la somme
150 millions de francs thompson
veut pas payer écrit à l'escroquerie
seulement voilà sirven aurait déjà versé
une avance 45 millions de francs
destinataires des fonds christine
deviers-joncour aujourd'hui les juges
d'instruction se demande quel rôle
l'ami de roland dumas a pu jouer dans ce
dossier auraient-elles monnayer
l'intervention éventuelle du ministre
des affaires étrangères juridiquement
rien ne le prouve
roland dumas se défend ah oui deux
plaques plus une saisine du procureur de
la république
dans le cas de sa compétence une plainte
pour diffamation et une plate pour
violation du secret d'instruction sont
elles sont pour le moment encore
d'instruction donc on peut parler
raconter vous souhaitez être entendu par
eva jeunes beauchamp lorsqu'elle pourra
entendre sur le fond roland dumas eva
joly aura peut-être quelques questions
de détail à lui poser les questions par
exemple sur cette information révélée
aujourd'hui par le journal le monde
la police financière aurait observé sur
le compte bancaire de roland dumas les
mouvements de fonds importants les
retraits des versements effectués en
1991 et 1992 c'est à dire justement à
l'époque de la signature du contrat des
frégates de taïwan
ce matin ont eu lieu à montigny le
bretonneux dans la région parisienne les
obsèques des neuf collégiens et de leurs
professeurs tués dans une avalanche
vendredi dernier dans les alpes
plusieurs milliers de personnes ont
assisté à cet adieu célébrée par
l'évêque de versailles reportage patrice
romedenne jacques dagor gaël audrey et
leurs camarades qui du coeur de chacun
ici ont fait leur tombeau aux portes du
gymnase ce parterre de fleurs traduit la
compassion de 5000 personnes qui
assistent aux obsèques avec un stoïcisme
dont seule l'émotion et le froid polaire
pourront avoir raison soixante-cinq
personnes victimes de malaises elles
vous disent un chagrin presque palpable
et dans la foule
le besoin parfois d'exprimer l'indicible
cet homme a perdu sa fille l'an dernier
à savon à la clé n'est pas fermée mais
j'irai le c2 est le seul mot il faut
s'accrocher viébel il faut continuer et
une période où tout sera difficile mais
je suis en s'accroche on apprend en
revenir à sourire mais monsieur combat
difficile à mener
tenter d'oublier c'est d'abord celui
géré au souvenir ce à quoi s'emploie le
professeur de français de la classe en
lisant des poèmes écrits par ses élèves
rescapés de l'accident
quand l'avalanche vous appris par la
hanche et que je n'ai rien vu rien
entendu
je n'ai pas pu non protégés même pas
vous sauvez bénir plutôt que maudire
dans son homélie l'évêque de versailles
met en garde contre un éventuel désir de
vengeance puis dans un cérémonial qui
emprunte autant la piété qu'à la fiction
la foule a communié au propre comme au
figuré
la monitrice de l'ucp a disparu
également vendredi dernier dans
l'avalanche a elle été enterrés
aujourd'hui dans son village natal de
l'enseigné dans le rhône la jeune femme
était âgée de seulement 22 cents pas de
nouveaux éléments dans l' enquête après
l'incarcération du guide responsable du
groupe son employeur lui cpa affirme que
daniel forte mise en cause avait
respecté les règles de la progression en
montagne par ailleurs dans le petit
village d'embrun dans les alpes une
cérémonie religieuse a également marqué
cette journée de recueillement vincent
nguyen vincent bouffartigue les gens de
la montagne aussi voulait rendre un
dernier hommage aux 11 victimes
emportées à jamais par l'avalanche
ce matin embrun une messe leur était
dédié une pensée pour les familles une
pensée aussi pour le guide de haute
montagne qui a passé sa première nuit en
prison
mise en examen pour homicide
involontaire que la justice suive son
cours mais
bonsoir disons dans l'amour et dans
l'amitié avec lui la femme du guide
exaspéré a exprimé aujourd'hui son
dégoût sur une radio locale
jusqu'à présent je ne voulais pas être
filmés et enregistrés par respect pour
les familles les ma propre famille n'ont
pas été respectées j'ai dû partir de ma
maison protéger mes enfants carrière des
journalistes étaient présents à l'école
ils n'ont pas de figure donc en respect
d'autres hommes alors là s'entendent
hier soir je m'adresse à tous ces soi
disant journalistes
vous l'avez sur la conscience vous êtes
responsable aux orres ses collègues
s'étonne de l'incarcération du guide
mais n'ont pas envie d'évoquer la sphère
et préfère parler de l'amie dont la vie
a basculé
c'est quelqu'un qui donnait beaucoup de
son temps pour que ton énergie qui
travaillaient bénévolement dans de
nombreuses associations
c'était quelqu'un de simple c'était
quelqu'un de calme c'était pas tous fous
c'était un passionné de la montagne et
passionné de pouvoir transmettre cette
passion même s'il désire que les
responsabilités soient établies et que
justice soit faite
beaucoup ici ont le sentiment qu'on
s'acharne sur un homme et rappelle que
le groupe était encadré de six adultes
devant les bases sur les 35 heures est
tout vert dans son discours de
présentation à l'assemblée nationale le
ministre de l'emploi martine aubry a
donné quelques nouvelles pistes de
discussion possible comme
l'établissement d'un smic à deux
vitesses horaires et mensuels insistant
sur le fait que cette loi n'est pas un
couperet comme le cnpf et l'opposition
la présente jean baptiste auprès d'ali
henry sera martine aubry se sait très
attendu sur les 35 heures pour son
projet de loi on annoncé une bataille un
affrontement c'est plutôt l'opposition
classique gauche droite
la majorité veut apparaître ressouder
les communistes soutiennent et les verts
d'habitude plus turbulents se font cette
fois les plus ardents supporters du
projet de l'ensemble c'est le projet de
loin le plus important de la législature
donc nous ferons tout pour qu'il
parvienne aboutissement non seulement
qu'ils soient votées dans cette
assemblée mais quand en plus pendant 18
mois et les vraies négociations entre
les partenaires
la majorité fait donc bloc en face
l'opposition dénonce avant tout la
méthode nous considérons que diminution
autoritaire
automatique de la durée de travail ne
créera pas d'emplois et mettra nos
entreprises en difficulté je crois qu'on
va véritablement en faire des
désillusions qu'en termes de pertes de
salaires en termes de pertes d'emplois
et donc on aura j'espère pesant pour
rectifier ce tir malheureux de la part
du gouvernement socialiste dans
l'hémicycle c'est plutôt l'apaisement à
quelques escarmouches près le ministre
de l'emploi répond par avance aux
critiques sur le passage aux 35 heures
en l'an 2000 ce n'est pas un couperet
puisqu'il s'agit de la durée légale
ce n'est pas un butoir puisque le
dispositif dead encourage ceux qui vont
plus vite et plus loin
c'est encore moins un carcan car le
champ de la négociation est immense pour
les neuf articles de la loi 6 jours
entiers de débats sont prévus malgré des
amendements par milliers martine aubry
paraît confiante pour réduire la durée
légale du travail
elle peut même prendre son temps
l'opposition politique en déposant
plusieurs centaines d'amendements marque
bien qu'elle entend batailler ferme
contre les 35 heures la position
officielle du patronat du cnpf est très
négative mais sur le terrain et bien les
positions de certains patrons
apparaissent parfois plus nuancée
reportage laurent bailly maire numério
lucien d'éden c'est un peu le patron à
l'ancienne un demi siècle dans le
bâtiment 70 salariés
l'homme est connu et respecté dans toute
la région de lille une génération autant
dire un fossé le sépare de thierry
descamps lui aussi est lillois lui aussi
dirige une entreprise de construction
qui compte une trentaine de salariés
les deux pdg sont au moins d'accord sur
un point les temps sont durs
envolées les glorieuses années 50 quand
les chantiers affluaient quand les
tarifs flambent et quand les charges
sociales atteignait à peine 5 % du
salaire d'un ouvrier contre +2 24%
aujourd'hui alors quand on lui parle des
35 heures lucien d'éden s'agace cette
loi dit il est inapplicable dans le btp
nous avons des ouvriers qui font s'ils
font 25 heures par semaine
compte tenu de dix heures de route parce
qu'on les envoie à valenciennes ou à
maubeuge et à des gens de route et des
heures de conduite ce sont des heures
travaillées
il faut 25 heures sur le chantier alors
je ne serait absolument pas compétitifs
dans le coin ou bien ils feront 35
heures sur le chantier
plus 10 heures de route et frère
d'infraction et je perds les heures
supplémentaires à 50 à 25 à 50 il est lé
repos compensateur en plus je ne serai
toujours pas compétitifs le résultat on
va rentrer les gens la région qui entend
bien obligé débauché du sonora - travail
thierry décor qui inspectent ici son
chantier du futur métro de rouve est
n'est pas du tout sur la même ligne avec
les primes de l'état pour chaque
nouvelle embauche et surtout si les
salariés acceptent l'annualisation du
temps de travail les 35 heures dit-il
profiteront à tous le monde lorsqu'un
salarié travaille 44 heures aujourd'hui
et bien heavy monsieur est à 5 heures
supplémentaires au delà 39 là donc il ya
un surcoût dans un système
d'annualisation du temps de travail
certaines semaines seront des semaines
de 25 ou 30 heures certaines semaines
seront des semaines de 46 heures le
compteur tourne dans un sens ou dans un
autre
et il n'y a pas de surcoût l'entreprise
fait un bénéfice de ce côté là et pour
embaucher
l'entreprise pourra embaucher dans ce
cas là en tout cas si les 35 heures sont
adoptées les deux pdg n'ont pas
l'intention de baisser les salaires
moi je me refuse on va créer un très
mauvais climat dans l'entreprise on peut
pas pêcher les salaires c'est pas
possible les salaires sont déjà beaucoup
trop bas dans cette entreprise comme en
france partout à cause de charges trop
élevées baisse ou maintien des salaires
annualisation ou non c'est dans chaque
entreprise que le rapport de force entre
syndicats et patrons va maintenant avoir
lieu avec pour tous cette question
combien d'emplois à la clé pour peser
sur le débat des 35 heures la cgt le
syndicat sud-rail principalement avait
lancé un mot d'ordre de grève qui a
perturbé la circulation des trains dans
toute la france aujourd'hui
la situation devrait s'améliorer demain
mais le trafic ne sera pas complètement
rétabli pour peser encore sur ce débat
des 35 heures plusieurs défilés à
l'appel de la cgt
dans des chômeurs aujourd'hui à toulouse
nantes lyon à marseille sur ces images
entre 15 cents et 3000 personnes
et puis à paris également entre quatre
et dix mille personnes selon que les
chiffres émanent de la police ou des
organisateurs ont défilé avec pour thème
donc des 35 heures mais aussi
l'augmentation des minima sociaux exigés
par le mouvement des chaumes l'actualité
internationale maintenant avec cette
dernière image dans la sphère clinton
images de mes 85-96 pardon qui montre
tout de même une certaine intimité entre
monica levinsky et le président
américain au cours d'une cérémonie
c'est la dernière trouvaille de la
presse américaine aujourd'hui dans cette
affaire pourtant rien de déterminant
n'est intervenu aujourd'hui dans l'
affaire de faux témoignage sur ses
fredaines amoureuse qui menacent donc le
président américain la vedette du jour
ce n'est pas le président mais sa femme
la première dame des etats-unis hillary
clinton qui est monté au créneau pour
défendre publiquement son mari et
dénoncer le complot politique dont il
serait victime washington maryse bureau
une femme bien décidé à défendre
l'honneur de son mari c'était ce matin à
new york hillary clinton combative dans
les studios de la chaîne de télévision
nbc combative et réitérant sa confiance
en son époux nous connaissons
parfaitement
nous comprenons nous acceptons et nous
nous aimons
je pense que tout cela est orchestré
pour amplifier les accusations contre
mon mari car tout le reste
quelques minutes plus tard la première
dame des etats-unis attaquent kenneth
starr le procureur dit indépendant et
chargés de l'enquêté vont ici un
procureur indépendant un convictions
politiques qui est l'allié des opposants
de droite de mon mari qui a
véritablement passé quatre ans à
vérifier nos coups de téléphone chat
l'échec que nous avons fait à remuer la
boue a intimidé des témoins à faire tout
son possible pour essayer de trouver une
accusation contre mon mariage à
washington pendant ce temps la chambre
de mise en accusation qui enquête sur la
sphère paula jones et donc la sphère
levinsky entame ses travaux
plusieurs témoins dont la secrétaire
personnelle du président américain sont
entendus aujourd'hui les journalistes
espérait l'apparition de la jeune monica
levinsky mais elle ne sera finalement
pas convoqué aujourd'hui il leur faut
donc se contenter aujourd'hui de cette
trouvaille du très sérieux washington
post
une petite annonce écrite par monica à
l'adresse du président c'était l'an
dernier pour la saint valentin
elle lui explique que les ailes légère
de leur amour l'ont fait voler au dessus
de la maison blanche
le discours que doit prononcer le
président ce soir ici devant le congrès
est un discours de politique intérieure
il ne devrait faire aucune référence aux
scandales en cours
cette allocution sera bien sûr diffusée
en direct par toutes les grandes chaînes
de télévision et nul doute que cette
année l'audience sera record mais pas
tout à fait pour les raisons souhaité
par le président américain est plus la
sphère monica levinsky s'éternise plus
elle a deux conséquences sur l'activité
du goût
en nommant américain et au delà sur
plusieurs grands dossiers internationaux
le premier par ordre de gravité étant le
processus de paix entre israël et les
palestiniens au point qu'en israël
un publicitaire a eu l'idée de lancer
une campagne en faveur du président
américain afin qu'il puisse de nouveau
se consacrer aux grands problèmes de ce
monde jérusalem charles enderlin
traduction on te soutient amis c'est
ainsi qu'une société de publicité de
tel-aviv exprime son amitié envers le
président des états unis
notre public considère clinton comme un
est mis en raison de ce qu'il fait en
faveur d'israël et du processus de paix
de fait les israéliens se souviennent
des visites de bill clinton à jérusalem
de son discours émouvant lors des
obsèques du sac rabin et il jouit ici
popularité inégalée
aujourd'hui le quotidien yediot aharonot
publie une interview de william ginzburg
l'avocat de monica levinsky celle par
qui le scandale est arrivé
ma cliente dit il aime israël et ne veut
pas faire tomber clinton mais les
relations entre benyamin nétanyahou et
le locataire de la maison blanche ne
sont pas bonnes le président américain
est en faveur de concessions
territoriales israéliennes aux
palestiniens et la droite ne serait pas
contre son départ devrait faire plus
attention à ce que dit monsieur bibi
netanyahou clinton est bon pour les
juifs d pas bon pour israël il est
pareil ça va se faire réélire donc pas
ce qu'il veut il aurait fait ce qu'il
veut c'est d'être bon contre deux tours
réaction des palestiniens il n'y a pas
de doute le scandale lewinsky distille
est un complot du lobby juif aux états
unis pour empêcher clinton de faire
pression sur netanyahu la relance du
processus de paix paraît plus lointaine
que jamais yasser arafat qui est rentré
aujourd'hui à gaza devra prendre des
décisions dans les tout prochains jours
du nouveau dans l'enquêté sur le meurtre
en irlande en des 196 de sophie toscan
du plantier la femme du producteur de
cinéma français un journaliste habitant
une maison voisine soupçonnés à
plusieurs reprises a été de nouveau
arrêté par la police à londres
étienne ménard
les journaux du soir dans la région de
cork ont tout juste eu le temps de
mettre l'information à la une et young
il est le suspect numéro un de la sphère
toscan du plantier a une nouvelle fois
été interpellé ce matin
depuis il est interrogé ici par les
enquêteurs qui reste silencieux sur
leurs intentions
son avocat sortie du commissariat en
milieu d'après-midi s'est lui aussi
refusé à tout commentaire journaliste à
ses heures voisin de sophie toscan du
plantier eion bailey avait déjà été
arrêté il y a un an puis relâché faute
de preuves il s'est toujours déclaré
innocent je n'ai strictement rien à voir
avec ce meurtre je suis totalement
innocent depuis un an les enquêteurs
irlandais estime avoir suivi toutes les
pistes possibles de l'arrivée de sophie
toscan du plantier à l'aéroport de cork
pour les fêtes de noël jusqu'au
centaines de personnes interrogées dans
les villages qui entoure sa maison
perdue sur la lande
la police irlandaise mise en cause par
certains pour sa lenteur et son
indécision
mais la famille de sophie toscan du
plantier qui était venu il y à un mois
en irlande pour une messe anniversaire
avait renouvelé sa confiance aux
enquêteurs la police irlandaise fait
c'est un très bon travail j'ai tout à
fait confiance en elle c'est une enquête
très difficile puisque ça a été un crime
horrible et je pense qu'il faut du temps
pour arriver à une solution ou à trouver
le coupable
le mystère de ce meurtre continue
d'obséder la région touristique de mise
en raid
on devrait savoir dans la soirée si eion
bailey au terme de sa garde à vue et
présentés à la justice
s'il est une nouvelle fois remise en
liberté
l'épave du chalutier de kamar el tout
landes 13 disparus avec ces cinq hommes
d'équipage en décembre dernier dans une
tempête au large du pays de galles a été
localisé pour la première fois par plus
de 100 mètres de fond vous le voyez
l'étude des images permettra peut-être
de recueillir des informations sur les
circonstances exactes du naufrage
alerte à la pollution du lait par de la
dioxine dans la région d'alevins dans le
nord la production de deux
établissements et ricol a été interdite
à la vente
les deux fermes sont situés près de
trois usines d'incinération d'ordures
ménagères qui seront fermés très très
prochainement un amour dominique maes
non caroline n'est pas en grève mais
depuis vendredi elle n'a plus le droit
de vendre ni fromage les yaourts dans le
lait de ses vaches
les services vétérinaires ont trouvé des
traces de dioxine un produit toxique
cancérigène
ici le taux est trois fois supérieur aux
normes recommandent envie de 80 % de
leur production laitière si on peut
faire de l'est à cause de lusine ben on
est des chômeurs c'est clair la cause de
cette interdiction
cette usine d'incinération juste
derrière la ferme on y brûle chaque
année des centaines de tonnes d'ordures
ménagères dans les fumées de la dioxine
elle se répand sur l'herbe brouter par
les h aucun risque pour la population
affirmé les autorités
et pourtant la sanction est tombée
lusine va fermé par précaution comme
deux autres en banlieue de lille
rien ne vaut que la tranquillité de la
population que la santé de la population
et surtout cette tranquillité
psychologique que je ne prenais pas peur
finalement deux top 6 j'y serai ici ou
là je crois que c'est très important
pour un problème très anciens à
wasquehal l'usiné construite en plein
centre ville
l'an passé ce rapport commandé par le
ministère de l'environnement il sans
appel les rejets d'acide chlorhydrique
sont six fois trop élevé depuis 10 ans
le maire se battait pour la fermeture ça
fait des mois que nous disons qu'il
était grand temps de fermer cette usine
par rapport disons à sa réalité
aujourd'hui c'est une victoire
les déchets vont maintenant être
détruits dans une usine du département
voisin
coût de l'opération 100 millions de
francs par an
le club med fleuron du tourisme français
pendant de très nombreuses années est
aujourd'hui en difficulté financière il
annonce cette année une perte de plus
d'un milliard de francs mais son nouveau
pdg philippe bourguignon ancien d'euro
disney espère le remettre rapidement sur
les rails il faut dire que le concept du
club méditerranée a quelque peu vieilli
et sa clientèle qui correspondait aux
années d'expansion économique et de
liberté sexuelle a vieilli également et
n'a pas été remplacé
reportage venez les fourneaux à la
nourrice qui l'idée de gilbert trigano
est simple et géniale vendre ses propres
tentes et des séjours de vacances
il vient d'inventer le club med dans
l'après guerre c'est un succès on ne
compte pas pour acheter et vendre du
rêve n'avait pas de rigueur financière
on mettait un certain village en effet
l'argent et on fait des comptes sur des
souris sur des bouts de papier l'argent
est même proscrit le gentiment drop est
avec les perles de son collier et le
tutoiement est de rigueur pour casser
les clivages sociaux paréo obligatoire
porte sans clé et ambiance bon enfant
dans les années 70 époque de liberté
sexuelle
c'est même devenu un phénomène de
société la parodie des bronzés en 82
fera chuter les ventes
mais si le public s'éloigne du club les
géo reste fidèle au patriarche triano
jusqu'à patri ation
on le vénère l'esprit de famille et les
méthodes de gestion artisanale auront du
mal à passer le cap des années 90 années
noires la menace du sida plane sur les
amours de vacances en 80 c'est la guerre
du golfe et en 92
un avion affrété par le club cette
phrase au sénégal bilan 30 morts et puis
il y à la crise et la concurrence
le club est copié le club devient cher
en 93 gilbert trigano passe le relais à
son fils mais les finances vont toujours
mal les actionnaires se rebiffe et serge
doit quitter la direction
en 90 s est pas notre conception à nous
du management de l'entreprise et de ce
qu'on avait envie de faire
le club a perdu sa famille trigano et
gagner une équipe d'experts de la
gestion avec à sa tête philippe
bourguignon
c'est un produit qui a su bien évoluer
avec son temps pour l'image est restée
figée un petit peu vers le passé que
l'on va donc faire évoluer et qui a un
potentiel extraordinaire aussi tenté
qu'ils soient poussés par une politique
de prix un peu plus agressive que nous
avons d'ailleurs mis en place un
objectif ambitieux au moment où le club
annonce le plus mauvais résultat de son
histoire 10% vaziani et demain dans les
4 vérités à 7h50 françoise laborde
recevra justement monsieur philippe
bourguignon
le président du directoire du club
méditerranée
il ya quelques années encore on appelait
ça le salon des arts ménagers
aujourd'hui il faut dire confortait
qu'un salon qui n'accueille désormais
que les professionnels et notre équipe
qui vous montrent maintenant ses
découvertes et les nouvelles tendances
de l'électroménager des appareils ultra
sophistiqué mais très simple à l'emploi
et beaucoup de couleurs pour remplacer
le blanc notamment pour les cuisinières
et les fous reportage elizabeth est gelé
jean louis goût serre décidément on ne
peut plus s'en passer
voici les cartes magnétiques à la
cuisine dans les fours à micro-ondes
elles ont des recettes en mémoire dont
elles programment automatiquement le
temps de cuisson ici même type de
performance mais le four et
traditionnelles et fonctionne par touche
50 recettes en mémoire et une fois cuit
les plats sont maintenus au chaud autres
nouveautés pratiques pour portions
individuelles le micro ondes à deux
étages intelligent aussi le premier lave
vaisselle au long cours
plus besoin de mettre du produit avant
chaque lavage une fois par mois suffi et
c'est la machine tout seul qui injectera
la dose nécessaire suivant les
programmes
c'est la grande sophistication des
appareils à l'intérieur qui les rend
simple à utiliser
mais il ya des limites le consommateur
doit s'adapter aussi peu à peu à la
simplicité et c'est pour ça que l'on
trouve encore sont beaucoup produit des
programmes que le consommateur peut
manoeuvrer lui même à côté de programmes
tout automatique il faut pas effrayer le
consommateur
pas besoin de s'adapter à cette
évolution technologique très rapide
beaucoup de couleurs aussi dans les
cuisines et des formes arrondies style
années 50
et quand le look est plus actuelle les
portes deviennent transparents plus
besoin de les ouvrir pour vérifier
l'état des provisions l'aspirateur malin
lui est équipé d'une brosse triangulaire
pour ne rien laisser dans les coins le
pèse personne raffiné est en verre moulé
et les petits appareils quotidien se
mettent à joindre l'agréable à l'utile à
la veille de l'inauguration du stade de
france à saint-denis en prévision de la
coupe du monde de football
le raid unité spécialisée de la police
répète un certain nombre de scénarios
catastrophe en cas d'accident
d'attentats ou de prise d'otage
reportage au nièce vahramian le
christian hottin bon tout le monde est
prêt là
on tape
non
c'est une agression contre l'équipe de
france à l'arrivée au vestiaire scénario
le moins probable peut-être le pire pour
le règle évacuer les joueurs maîtriser
les hommes en armes
la réaction ne peut excéder quelques
secondes notre but c'est sauver la vie
d'un sportif avant tout il faut des gens
motivés qui n'hésite pas qu'ils savent
exactement ce qu'ils doivent faire dans
ce genre de conditions qui ne soient pas
en train de poser des questions leur
mission pendant la coupe du monde ne
sera pas le maintien de l'ordre mais la
protection des personnalités attentats
prise d'otages au grand stade le raid a
étudié toutes les possibilités
d'évacuation rapide il y a les tunnels
et l'hélicoptère bien sûr la pièce
maîtresse on va essayer de vue la
pelouse de pas poser l'hélicoptère
dessus mais avec les patins vous voyez
qu'on arrive à se tenir prêts ce cas
limites du seul donc à n'importe quel
endroit du stade
on va pouvoir élever en hélicoptère on
va de l'actualité sociale inspirent les
exercices mais c'est l'acte isolé sur le
passage une personnalité que l'on craint
avant tout depuis huit mois ces hommes
protègent déjà l'équipe de france et
auront en charge ces autres délégations
dont la liste n'est pas arrêté et du
clac
il était central de lutte antiterroriste
qui évalue la menace est donc qui nous
dit quelles sont les équipes à protéger
plus particulièrement et c'est fluctuant
et ça peut ça peut évoluer d'ici la
coupe du monde
derniers repérages au-dessus du grand
stade aujourd'hui les hommes du raid
sont encore en noir demain sur le
terrain
ils porteront un plus discret costume
cravate
la coupe du monde de football elle est
également une énorme entreprise qui va
générer des profits considérables en
matière d'image de marque et de
résultats financiers comprenez donc dans
ces circonstances et bien rien et à
proviseur tout est fortement réglementée
c'est le thème de notre enquête de ce
soir christophe duchiron frédéric
bazille la coupe du monde de football et
son célèbre trophée en or massif
les joueurs des spectateurs par
centaines de milliers et 37 milliards de
téléspectateurs cumulés
l'événement de sport le plus médiatisé
le plus exposé du siècle la coupe du
monde de football
le jeu et les enjeux aujourd'hui même au
centre d'entraînement de l'équipe de
france à clairefontaine
une célèbre boisson gazeuse organise une
opération de promotion auprès de jeunes
footballeurs
les meilleurs d'entre eux seront porte
drapeau ramasseur de balle lors du
prochain mondial
coca la pub et la coupe du monde de foot
ça fait vingt ans que ça dure pour
l'édition 98 coca parquet en douce très
gros sponsor de l'épreuve quiquet
d'entrée pour ces multinationales entre
100 et 200 millions de francs pour faire
la promotion de sa marque à l'échelle
internationale
coca à payer pour profiter de
l'événement et surtout coquet à penser à
ses consommateurs
ce que nous voulons c'est partager leur
passion c'est partager leur joie
c'est de s'associer à tous ceux qui
vaille le football parfois avec la
défaite des nous espérons cette année
avec beaucoup de victoires
pénétrons maintenant dans une autre
dimension
voilà le cri cup gadgets sonore pour
supporters étienne dulin de villedieu
les poêles en normandie chef
d'entreprise son objectif vendre les
cris cup avec logo et mascotte france 98
seulement depuis six mois il a sans le
feu vert de sony le géant japonais la
société qui accorde les droits
d'utilisation de la marque coupe du
monde
beaucoup de gens ne comprennent pas
qu'on ne m'ait pas donné ce
référencement parce que devant un
produit sympa
la mesure on est prêt à payer des
royalties dans la mesure où il ya des
ventes e
on honore en général nos contrats je
vois pas pourquoi aujourd'hui parce que
je n'ai pas de raison on m'a dit vous ne
l'aurez pas mais je n'ai pas de raison
précise
j'attends il monsieur dulin n'a sans
doute pas fini d'attendre car sony
estime qu'il a un réseau de distribution
insuffisant pas assez de points de vente
pas assez de profits donc pas
d'autorisation le rêve de monsieur dulin
fait rentrer le cri club dans la
boutique france 98 sur les champs
elysées avec un produits référencés
comme cela il aurait le droit d'utiliser
la mascotte haut l'emblème coupe du
monde aujourd'hui il se dit prêt à
écouler 500 mille à un million de pièces
sans licence officielle il en vendra
sans doute dix fois moins il est évident
que si vous avez le choix entre un tee
shirt blanc et un t-shirt qui porte la
mascotte du monde
si le nom du sport est impitoyable le
nom des affaires c'est pareil cette
semaine les joueurs de l'équipe de
france ont touché leur nouveau paquetage
pour la coupe du monde
un contrat en or pour une célèbre marque
aux trois bandes à l'entraînement des
bleus ces jours ci un homme veille
gilles bloch maillots chaussures ballon
chaussettes survêt l'air de rien l'homme
à la moustache s'assure que le logo
s'affiche partout
je n'ai pas du tout la vocation d'être
un garde chiourme d'ailleurs je pense
pas que auprès des joueurs
j'ai ce rôle à jouer car ils sont
professionnels ils savent ce qu'ils ont
à faire
la coupe du monde de football sur le
terrain du jeu ce sera disputé sur le
terrain des affaires et des sponsors
c'est un peu la même chose dans un
premier temps il faut se qualifier
ensuite il ya la compétition et là coup
de millions il faut gagner à ce moment
là alors la coupe du monde peut devenir
une affaire en or
voici la composition de l'équipe de
france qui jouera demain soir contre
l'espagne parmi les 11 titulaires une
seule véritable surprise diomède
l'auxerrois sélectionné pour la première
fois et qui fait partie de l'équipe type
à cette occasion publication également
par l' agence france-presse du guide du
mondial 98 avec photo et renseignements
sur toutes les équipes participant à la
compétition le tennis maintenant
internationaux d état d'australie pardon
disparition de la française sandrine
testud batterie lui par l'espanyol
conchita martinez surprise également
l'élimination de l'américain pete
sampras numéro un mondial battu en
quatre sets par le slovaque kucera 20e
mondiale seulement à noter également que
la nuit prochaine à 2 heures du matin
vous pourrez suivre sur france 2 le
quart-de-finale féminin
mary pierce contre martina hingis
si les mains sortie parmi les sorties de
cette semaine en france un film
américain tiré d'une pièce à succès qui
s'est longtemps joué à new york
amour valeur et compassion l'histoire
douce amère qui nous amène à partager le
temps d'un week-end la vie de quatre
couples point particulier ils sont
homosexuels
on rit beaucoup mais l'émotion pointe au
coin de chaque scène au brier de l'air à
christian hottin fièrement les respects
gueule tout de même lecteur ventes
d'yves hecker représente les valeurs
d'une certaine amérique
- proche du middle west que de new york
où la pièce dont s'inspire le film a
fait partie des classiques pendant
plusieurs années
de prime abord tout semble plutôt
ordinaire
quatre couples professions libérales ou
artistes l'élite branche est en quelque
sorte se retrouvent le temps d'un week
end à la campagne
mais dans cette histoire là les huit
copains sont tous homosexuels
ce n'est pas un film sur les homosexuels
mais sur les relations humaines
comment les gens font face à la mort
comment ils profitent des bons moments
de la vie au contraire comment ils se
replient sur eux-mêmes
c'est tout simplement un film sur les
gens comme parfois dans la vie les
quatre couples se défont se recomposant
au hasard des rencontres
et s'il reste toujours 8 à aimer la
campagne le jeu de séduction et des
rancunes semble plus palpable
qu'ailleurs
ben ali
comme au quotidien la maladie est aussi
présente ici c'est le sida qui joue le
rôle de la mort mais ce film offre un
joli moment ampli d'amitié de tendresse
le festival du cirque de monaco se
termine ce soir par un hommage à annie
fratellini récemment disparu fondatrice
de la première école du cirque en france
et dans toute l'europe occidentale
d'ailleurs c'est à son compagnon pierre
et textes que cet hommage a été confiée
reportage à jerada mme annie fratellini
que voici avec sa fille valérie le
disait comme shapping dans le siècle on
reste toujours à la mac
la vie n'est pas assez long pour devenir
un artiste
annie pensée ouvrait sur tradition pure
et dure celle enseignée à l'école
nationale du cirque véritable formation
qui ne reçoit que des oboles de
subventions le charivari mélange de
disciplines surtout acrobatie danse les
bases qui ouvre sur les autres
disciplines
le cirque histoire d'amour entre le rêve
et l'exigence sa dot d'abord une
technique tous les jeunes qui passent à
l'école du chiac doivent apprendre un
métier comme des artisans et le faire au
plus haut niveau c'est à dire que s'ils
n'en sont pas capables ils voulu qu'ils
arrêtent ces skis de fond c'est ce que
j'essaie de l'autisme et lyonnais
voudrait passer d'eux s'arrête
il vaut mieux continuer à bien ce
chantier il ne pas habiter 300 élèves du
monde entier ainsi d'ailleurs que les
professeurs tous attirés par le label
fratellini la jeune lee répète
inlassablement sa voltige cavalière sous
l'oeil d'un connaisseur pierre et ex
annie et pierrot fondé l'école en 74 la
première école occidental pour le couple
c'était à la fois un devoir et un
plaisir
ça
et cet amour on a eu de faire ce
métier-là d'amuseur public
on a aimé le transmettre aux autres et
on a aimé d'autres y viennent aussi l'un
des clous de la formation le trapèze 10
en grand ballon jean christophe pons
pierrick tual dany revient d'un contrat
de trois ans le chapiteau américain
barnes
l'ancien élève encore des images
suspendu dans son souvenir
elle était un peu notre mère du cirque
dont elle nous a forcément a pris vous a
donné son éducation m
premièr hommage à annie fratellini ce
petit bout de femme talentueuse et
courageuse qui a quitté la piste aux
étoiles
c'était 10 et elles sont rondes paradis
c'est donc ce soir à paris le rappel des
principaux titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi d'abord perquisition trois
perquisitions dans les domiciles au
bureau de roland dumas président du
conseil constitutionnel dans le cadre
d'une affaire de pots-de-vin à
l'occasion d'un important marché
militaire signant 91
le débat sur les 35 heures est ouvert à
l'assemblée nationale pour l'instant les
positions sont très éloignées entre
majorité gouvernement et opposition
plusieurs défis dont celui aujourd'hui
et puis hillary clinton la première dame
des etats-unis vient au secours du
président son mari elle dénonce un
complot politique
voilà dans un instant la météo sophie
davant 20h55 le grand film de ce soir le
retour du grand blond avec pierre
richard et mireille la voilà je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
chaîne ou retrouveront demain soir à 20
heures je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée donc bon soir demain